thank you
[Music]
all right welcome back to another
awesome episode of the careful boys
today we have Mr Lawrence Cal here wow
wow
[Applause]
he's not the focus of the story or the
attention today we're going to talk
about
this guy oh that's why he's not here
today he's doing a bodybuilding
competition Mr Burt Quan himself look at
those stripes he's gonna wear g string
on stage holy [__] let's yeah right dude
he caught a lot yeah did you know he
weighs less than Mino
holy [__] bro
it's like 160 right now oh it's no it's
not easy
or something right yeah 160 yeah 168. if
he was 160 he'd be a very small boy
that's crazy how much does he win it's
like 167 eight whatever totally by the
time this video is up I don't know
buy back to 210.
is the competition today tomorrow
so why isn't he here now yeah what the
[__] he doesn't seem funny anymore he's
not funny he's funnier when he's fat
yeah yeah look at his back not funny no
he's skinny he doesn't have the calories
to make jokes hey you want to know
oh
I like that's fun Bart that's fun Bart
Bert Barton Bart dude so right now his
meals are like 200 something calories a
day
our pictures up per meal per meal it's
like this much like meat and then this
much broccoli how how long is this
middle finger yeah that one right there
holy [__]
he's flipping off his food his finger
looks weird in that picture I think
today is gonna be a fast I don't think
he's eating anything today he ate cereal
oh is that what it was he got said he
was allowed to yeah he's gonna [__] him
up and Spike his insulin
it's gonna make his muscles pop dude
it's gonna make him look all sexy you
know
right anyway would you ever do a
bodybuilding show nah I don't think so
what I don't know I don't know I don't
know I'm not gonna say no it's anything
so maybe do it maybe probably not though
I don't really have any interest in
doing bodybuilding I will do it if you
don't have to stop eating well I think
that's half of it I know maybe they have
like bodybuilding competitions where you
can build fat
oh yeah oh you know what body positivity
building competition everybody
positivity building like look at this
guy he doesn't give a [__] yeah let's do
a cholesterol building show look how
positive four zero [__] I pay my bills
my bills are paid sorry if you don't
know whoever Anthony Lee show them your
slabs dude slabs that's what we call ABS
dude oh see I don't even know because
I'm not a bodybuilder you're about to be
I'm not gonna [__] when Bart started
cutting we all kind of started like
losing weight a little bit collectively
as a group you get started with David
David David's the reason why Bart looks
so easy
David huh Davidson who was the first you
know me David and Barb got fat together
yeah but I think David was the first to
start losing weight was he yeah well he
felt like he needed I do like a long
time ago though wasn't it you that
helped him lose the weight it was look
like he I was there at the time look man
what level with you all right I'm in
level David's pretty self-motivated yeah
David he just went for it bro like he he
that was like one of his big goals so
it's like when you make that why'd you
say the word big huh it was one of his
fattest goals he had to say you know
what I mean and that's what he wanted to
Chase and that he was really motivated
to do that so you know yeah he did he
did a good job losing a lot of his uh
funny calories
you talking about David yeah yeah he's
not as funny anymore he's definitely not
as funny
he's just more Angry yeah he's scary now
like when he's hungry yeah yeah I get it
but you know David lost well he lost
like 60 pounds
that's a lot that's a lot that's really
cool and when I saw David for seeing him
now and you see old videos of David like
when he's punching the wall or the clips
that you post on JK you're like holy
[__] Dave used to be a lot bigger yeah
it is you look so different he sort of
looks like Mike's song yeah a little bit
in every David is a little Mike song I
Gotta show you guys so Geo was uh
sending us fat Bart and I was like [__]
dude fat Bard is [__] fat how fat is
fat Bart what what how much are we
talking right here Barnes probably lost
like 40 pounds as well how much weight
is that though like what is that weight
that's gotta be like 210
or two yeah it's got to be two because
Bart is not necessarily like he's but
that means that's 40 pounds you're
talking about David losing 60 pounds but
I lost 40. yeah that's crazy for his
size that's [__] fat
laughs
GEOS Texas what a night
you're sending us his before pictures
dude this is but since Bart's been doing
his bodybuilding prep I think we all
kind of slowly randomly you know let's
start losing weight like at bodybuilding
shows do you get credit for what you
started as like you should you really
should the before and after right that
seems like a lot of uh but the thing
about bodybuilding shows like if you're
a like a bodybuilding competitor you're
doing it pretty frequently this is like
Bart's first show yeah this is the first
attempt of him trying to be like [__] it
I'm just gonna do this and see what
happens yeah and he looks shreddy dude
super short you know how long you have
to do that dieting and all that to prep
for a bodybuilding show like I think it
looks like he's been on this for a year
yeah it depends on like how much you
need to cut he did say a year right it's
holy [__] he said for the year he's like
been yeah so like pretty diligent I
think when the like the real
hard calorie cutting is like
probably like 12 weeks sometimes eight
weeks it depends on like where you're at
too you know I have no idea I've never
really done anything like that he was he
sent in a group text that I that we have
um the other day and he goes I totally
forgot the schedule my brain's not even
working today yeah see and I'm like
that's crazy because remember Jared when
he was here he was prepping for a show
yeah and his mind was pretty sharp right
he said he took a bunch of stuff to be
able to get him through JK yeah he did
say that normally it's like like foggy
and stuff but that fool's a genius
though yeah that Jared feather so he's
probably a genius normally and then yeah
bodybuilding he's like us
no for sure so anytime Jared's gonna do
a bodybuilding show we're like come on
the show dude come on now anytime he's
prepping now that you're at our level so
does he have to do like does he have to
learn the poses yeah
training so someone teaches you like
these are the things you got to do Bart
was saying that was the hardest part he
was posting the clip uh he posted a clip
about how his coach was telling him he's
like you know when you're like posing
like this you want to tilt forward a
little bit to catch the lighting a
certain way because the judges are lower
than you yeah so there's all these like
tips and tricks to make sure that you're
showing them striations you know it's
like a whole explanation about how like
you used to show you this shoulder even
though you're this way yeah I'm like
Jesus Christ
getting [__] lighting the right way
that's like Dude I can't I can't wait to
see spray tan bars yeah does he oil up
I'm sure would you guys rather do they
do all right like two competitions would
you rather do a male uh beauty pageant
or a bodybuilding competition I'd rather
do it
well for the beauty pageant does that
mean you have to like lean out like Mr
Universe yeah what do you got to do with
the beauty pattern do you have to like
make your own dress type [__] you have
to have a special talent no you gotta
have it yeah you gotta ask questions
yeah you're gonna have different outfits
you're gonna have a swimsuit you got a
talent thing yeah so then you have to
have a speech you have to have a little
piece bro yeah world peace is a big
thing
I think it'd be more fun to try and get
ready for a bodybuilding competition I'd
rather do that hey let's all do a
bodybuilding you guys are homophobic I
don't like that homophobic
not willing to look gay
you mean we're about to be with a bunch
of other dudes that are wearing like
G-strings
I think doing a bodybuilding show would
have lasting benefit rather than pageant
right yeah you're hungry
your metabolism do you have to be like
super skinny nope oh you could just look
at you you can body build too yeah you
can you can be in shape you can make
speeches and get in shape it's the
all-around one is the all-around and one
is just physical physical because Bart's
probably what like [__] five percent
body fat
he said no he was like at eight or nine
the other day yeah five five gets really
those [__] get shreddy though
dude they got [__] lean you know but
he started at like like 25 or some [__]
but you're looking like that
it's bad die if I did that
do you think I would die
that showed me though I think it thrived
stop playing that show me under every
fat guy is a rip guy
for real
yeah um so you're saying under every fat
person has they all have muscles like
human anatomy did you know under
every fat belly there's a six-pack there
just waiting to come out
it's also much stronger from having to
carry so much weight
no that's the other
underneath you ever see David's cabs
Davis calves are crazy he got big thick
calves and look at my calves tiny dude
what are you trying to say that's why he
has such hard kicks huh yeah that's true
you said what that's why his kicks are
so good huh yeah David hits like a
[__] truck but anyways I have small
tiny caps let me Rush against some
weight let's all do a bodybuilding shot
dude I'm down all right let's all do one
Come on Anthony look at Anthony Anthony
looks shreddy right now I'm wearing a
long sleeve shirt how can you tell show
the picture you showed me earlier Super
Bowl bets we'll all do a bodybuilding
show but he has to do the pageant
you always have to go against it I know
yeah if I I don't care I'm not
homophobic all right let's test it out
um I don't have to change I don't have
to prepare yeah you gotta at least wash
your hair you gotta have outfits bro you
gotta it's a whole thing
let's test them out let's ask what's
that famous question most Americans
cannot find Iraq on a world map why do
you think that is
they don't learn geography oh my God so
brave
something powerful in the way he says it
have you seen that clip yeah where did
he asked her that she she had some like
long ass answer that makes no sense I
think I wouldn't say it the same thing
work for work oh my God that's a lot of
pressure dude that's a tough one when
she goes I like World Peace what the
[__] what the [__] why are they even
asking her that question you know like
what is the point of that what do you
think of world peace no the question of
like most people can't find a rack on a
map like what do you think of this like
what the [__] do I care if she what's
her opinion on it because I think for
she has to have brains and Beauty it's
all around yeah I think that's the joke
though yeah yeah oh okay I see it's like
a mean joke huh but her because she
ended up
but her answer centered more along like
if you could even find one thing she was
saying that because they don't have Maps
yeah that's right
the schools don't have Maps
or just people
but there's a lot of words around that
answer you can see her sweat and I was
like I've been there before and then
Mario Lopez after is all well okay all
right hey you better signing out doesn't
Trump own all those beauty pageants I
think so I think the universe one right
oh really I can't remember which one it
was but yeah one of them he did I don't
know if all of them I feel like they all
lost their Prestige that they used to
have really I think culture sort of
shifted too yeah I think anyone really
gives a [__] about you well actually no
the Miss Universe people were watching
that [__] they were eating it up because
who won the the girl you Miss USA one
right some [__] she was like half
Filipino the Filipino one of a year a
couple years back yeah oh so that was
years ago does it work like
the the Miss different states funnel up
to Miss America funnels up to Miss
Universe yeah yeah usually yeah but all
those people in pageants do pageants all
the time that's like there's yeah their
thing yeah so even if you have like a
Miss Universe chances are she's already
won someone you know what they should
stop immediately is children's beauty
pageants that was [__] weird what do
you you don't like them
no dude who who watches that remember
that one with the with the grandpa women
women watch it really that's weird
remember that correct the prime demo oh
a Little Miss Sunshine love that movie I
saw it the other day still holds up
you didn't if it wasn't bodybuilding is
there something else another
he's computer
yeah yeah
that's true it's closed doors if you had
to do something to compete in correct
right you can't choose what you're like
good at like oh dude then he can't
choose Jiu-Jitsu agree it has to be
something completely different America's
Best Dance Crew and I start my crew with
the dancers okay go [__] yourself clean
go ahead
he's the only one there but he's he's in
a room with five other deflectors yeah
and you'd be in the room with me Colleen
that's a good question questions that go
go on yeah so what would you guys
compete in what kind of competition so
like a hobby but I'm not good at it yeah
mountain biking oh mountain bike oh [__]
that's intense so you so you'd have to
train to a certainly have to train dude
a triathlon would be cool golf but
there's no [__] way that you could
get to it you don't believe in yourself
there's tournaments you don't go against
people who've been [__] training
their whole life for that though that's
the level yeah but they're not a Kinja
dude
lower yeah
yeah you're not gonna make it to the PGA
bro it's the the local uh like uh like a
celebrity amateur type of situation
where I'm partnered with like James
hardeners yeah dude you guys would smash
I think you would do golf for sure the
answer is fun to like put hella time
into but like that's still so hard oh
you don't like those this isn't a a real
competition but that TV show where you
just gotta survive and go to a
checkpoint I want to do that the bear
gryll [__] oh that sounds scary oh wow
oh you're right like I love the TV show
alone I would love to try something like
that but I know I would lose but Naked
and Afraid naked and alive I don't I
wouldn't want to be naked I'm depressed
for it like so you get some sort of
survival skill so you have a year so
yeah let's say you have a year prior
just like art to prep for you know what
I want to do I'd want to be in compete
in The Cannonball or the Gumball 3000
what's that it's the race that uh starts
in New York and it ends in LA and it's
whatever you can [__] do to get there
first what that's cool
um
you have to you have to have your car
and there's checkpoints like you you get
you clock in and out from every
checkpoint but you can't get you can't
speed huh no you got whatever you got
what car would you drive uh so the
famous thing is like at the first one
that ever happened the guy who almost
won he was in an ambulance in a way
but he like swapped the motor out so it
was like a race [__] ambulance yeah
but then it broke at the very end that
he didn't win it but then the movie that
they made called Cannonball Run is made
by the guy who did that race that's so
tight is there like a grand prize what's
the I think it's like honestly the
people that do this are so rich that
they do it just to [__] do it oh
that's tight like they're like Rich ass
dudes that do this race yeah can you
imagine halfway through
he's like [__] yeah it's hard to like
you'd have to be tactical you'd have to
choose a really smart vehicle to like
like something fast could you go to
certain checkpoints to get like your car
fixed and other things like that because
it's just the first one who gets there
yeah you can you I mean you have to fix
your [__] if it's if it's busted but
yeah it's it's checkpoints so your time
is allotted at the very end once you get
to La and they'll put all your cards
together and be like okay that's cool
this time yeah that sounds really fun so
you could get there later than the um
you could get second at the last
checkpoint but the other ones you could
have blazed through you know but then
your total Time Shows if you want do you
think you're a good driver
I think I'm a crazy driver I think I
think I'm clever enough because I did
one from LA to Vegas with a with a rally
crew yeah but then that was like I think
I got like seventh or eighth I don't
know how many people I did it in a
DeLorean too no [__] way but it was
don't you say it's a shitty car it is
yeah but it's but the thing is it's like
uh it's like for fun like we people
weren't going too crazy and we went
through like the checkpoint we went
through Pahrump and [__] it was like it
was like more of like a Scenic fun route
and then you stopped at the checkpoints
and you party but it's like not a
serious thing yeah yeah but if but the
gumball one or the Cannonball Run is
like serious like people think of the
craziest things to do it it's like nuts
all the guys that got stuck at Pahrump
you know what happened
[Laughter]
yeah it's like a it's like um yeah like
a little small little town what would
you do Colleen
got her good transition I probably do I
don't know maybe a few things either
boxing oh [__] or maybe like Formula One
I think that would be really fun to like
compete in well because you would have
like a year of training right holy [__]
that'd be cool
you wouldn't do a like a a DP
competition
like she said she said you can't do what
you're naturally already doing
oh well what if it's like holding up a
boom mic carts I'll do I'll do like real
hardcore gold cards
some sort of Hardcore go-kart that would
be so much fun yeah
maybe like a triathlon
do you not normally do that at all I
mean I run but I don't like really swim
have you done a marathon yeah
how did you like that it was um intense
you want to do Spar races do it again
what races we should do JK sport races
bro I would love to do that come on JK
Spartan races we had we had one before
[__] bring it I've never done one
it's fun it's pretty easy what are the
dude I want to see I want to see Steve
get ready for a Spartan Race dude Steve
is also getting in shape Too Bethel was
showing off the buys and tries the other
day do a five mile one you could do a
middle one is like six to eight mile or
you could do a half a marathon yeah
and it's just running together dude
marathons no there's obstacles in
between I couldn't make it to my mirror
I respect people that could do marathons
[__] is annoying
climbing ropes tires like random [__]
[__] you're in teams right there's no
you could do it by yourself for Tough
Mudder there's Tough Mudder that one's
like more fun the obstacles are like for
fun and Spartan's more like we did have
them under uh with Alan and uh oh you
did oh we won we got first place what
the Irvine Tough Mudder no way good [__]
Irvine though yeah
I want to see if I got better because
everyone's just like
dirty instead of the tattoos
dude smart race is fun I've never done
one yeah it's really cool I will say to
bring it back to Bart at the end of this
video I texted him to try and give him
some good juicy going into this week's
competition and he was like I'm never
doing this again and then we cracked up
because he was like I legit thought that
I was about to do this competition with
double Shin tattoos
that would have got it that would have
been the best he would have
so he's not eating anything today or
he's fasting he ate cereal
cheater